JENNY BROWN: In
our previous video,
we looked at how
enable broadening
and disable keyword
search can help
you adjust the
number of jobs that
are returned from a search.
Let's talk about
two more options,
featured jobs and
custom ranking,
to further influence
your search results.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First up, you have the
ability to feature a job
by setting a promotion value.
This is a property
actually attached
to each individual job posting.
When performing a search
request against the API,
you can filter if you want only
featured jobs to be returned.
Using featured jobs
allows you to highlight
jobs that are important in
terms of your business needs.
Any featured jobs are returned
in order of promotion value.
If multiple jobs have
the same promotion value,
the relevance of the job
listing is used as a tiebreaker.
However, it's important to
balance not only how you're
showing featured jobs, but
also ensuring the relevance
of search results.
If you only show
featured jobs which
are ordered by your
promotion value,
you may not be returning
the highest quality
matches for a search request.
This means that the user
may not be exactly seeing
the best experience and
could have lower engagement.
So it's important to
balance your implementation
with the number and
presentation of featured jobs.
Also, when searching
for featured jobs
you can use enable
broadening, so you
have expanded query
results that come back
when doing a search request.
One important note
is that we recommend
not using featured jobs when
disable keyword match is
set to false.
This can lead to a
featured job being
promoted when it could be fairly
irrelevant to the user's query.
For example, if
you featured a job
for a software engineer
with a server administration
in the description
and someone searches
for a restaurant
server, they may
see this software engineering
job as the top match.
With keyword matching,
this job fits the criteria,
and coupled with being featured,
it might end up towards the top
and provide a poor
experience for the user.
Again, it's important
to make sure
the configuration makes
sense for your use cases
and that you test to
get the best results.
Featured jobs lets you
split off certain jobs
to be returned separately,
but you can also
use custom ranking to influence
the order in which jobs
are returned.
Custom ranking can be done
through an expression where
you create a
formula to influence
the ordering of results.
These formulas can involve
simple math and custom
attributes for jobs, which
we'll talk a bit more
about in the next video.
When setting a custom
ranking formula,
the jobs in the
search result will
get returned according
to your formula,
giving you more control
over ordering them.
Based on the way you want
jobs to return and to keep
job search results relevant,
you should use featured jobs
or custom ranking.
However, we don't
really recommend
using both at the same time.
They're both powerful
tools to give you
the customization support
to meet your business logic,
but they're two ways of
solving the same problem.
So using them at
the same time can
be hard to manage and
give confusing results
for your users.
Featured jobs and
customer ranking,
along with broadening
and keyword matching,
are major ways to
configure and tweak
the results that come back
from the job search API.
In our next video, we'll look at
some more configuration options
that are a bit smaller,
and best practices
to keep in mind when you're
testing out your integration.
Thanks for watching,
and remember,
when looking for talent, it's OK
to keep your head in the cloud.